i don't make resolutions anymore i have
a word so at my
dinner table we all go around the table
and we say
what's your word for this year certainly
during the time i was at harvard
i wasn't sure what i was going to do you
pay a lot of money
you know for school and then you have
this pressure um
to get out and get a job or to do
something with it want to be happy
build a life not just a business
[Music]
hey it's evan carmichael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number one challenge that is holding
you back
a lack of belief in yourself you watch
these videos because you
know you're capable of more you've got
michael jordan level genius
at something so today let's live your
best believe life and learn how
billionaires think and get some success
advice from the top
enjoy
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one always keep learning with bill gates
certainly during the time i was at
harvard
i wasn't sure what i was going to do uh
the idea that software was this field
that uh
was the opportunity was unbelievable
that became more obvious
during the three year period i was here
but my dad had been a lawyer
i thought of mathematics you know like
doing well in the putnam
that was the coolest thing uh and the
computer software
i didn't think those people were as
smart as the math people so it's like
well
am i going to go into the easy field or
this really hard
field but anyway math
uh was fantastic when i finally picked
and decided to go go do microsoft then i
got into a period
from age uh 19 uh
to about 40 where i wasn't able to
look at the latest on you know how
tornadoes work or
how mitochondria work i was pretty
monomaniacal
and when i was able to ask steve this is
the year 2000 c
balmer uh he he mistakenly graduated
uh but then he started it stan
but i was trying to hire him but his
parents told him you're supposed to
graduate which was fine
but then he started at stanford business
school
and he was in his first year and i
thought this is perfect i'll get him to
drop out of
stanford business school uh so in a
certain sense he is a dropout
uh and he was very key to the success of
microsoft i mean
uh he knew a lot of things but during
that period i didn't get
to do much at harvard you know i took
all these courses because
it was just so amazing that people were
interested in talking about that
and i i have to say
i never went to a lecture during reading
period or any anything because the
courses that i was actually signed up
for i finally started
to work on those uh so i was in hillel
the minute would open
to the minute it would close during
reading period trying to catch up on
on that other set of courses so people
say i'm a dropout which
is literally true but
because i like college courses the
online
college courses there's a company called
the learning company that i buy
uh tons and tons of their stuff and i do
you know at least four or five courses a
year
in a sense i like uh going to college
more than anyone
so i've sort of made sure my job
certainly post-microsoft that i get to
spend my time meeting with scientists
learning new things you know seeing what
the hard problems are
in some cases giving money to people to
take on
those very very hard problems rule
number two think
long term with warren buffett i was
wondering how do you decide
what you invest your time and money in
yeah well i i
i like to find
businesses that have good economics now
what what are good economics well good
economics are a business that has
some kind of a moat around it that
makes its product or its service or its
location or something
a little more desirable than to the
customer than any other sort of
comparable product
uh you know the number one candy bar in
the last 30 or 40 years has been
snickers
people don't fool around with different
candy bars they fool around with
different
length dresses they fool around you know
with all kinds of things but they don't
fool around with candy bars
because they figure you know they're
going to go in and lay out 50 cents or
whatever it is and put it in their mouth
and they're not going to for 50 cents
and putting in your mouth i mean you're
not going to say i'll
i'll put in i'll lay out 45 cents and
put something else in my mouth so
you find that very stable and we like
businesses
that we think we can figure out where
they're going to be in 10 or 15 years
i don't know where the information
technology businesses are going to be in
10 or 15 years i know where snickers
bars are going to be in 10 or 15 years
they're going to be selling just about
this you know the way they do now
i know where wrigley's gum is going to
be in 10 or 15 years but there's not
going to be a lot of innovation
in in chewing gum uh the and people the
internet's not gonna cause people to
quit chewing gum either i mean at least
i mean gates may think so but i don't
think so but uh
[Music]
it's it's predictability
the sustainability of a competitive
advantage some something special about a
product
rule number three know your purpose with
oprah winfrey
i don't make resolutions anymore i have
a word so at my dinner table
we all go around the table and we say
what's your word
for this year okay and my word is
purpose
my word for this year is purpose because
when i look back on my you know how you
can't even figure out what you did in a
year because your life's so full
yeah so another now i just go back and i
look through my phone so i was doing
that
on new year's eve looking through the
phone at all the pictures all the stuff
you've done
and i did a lot of things but i didn't
do a lot of things
on purpose with intentional purpose
so my thing this year is don't do
anything unless you have an intention
and a purpose behind it rule number four
be a student of
observation with grant cardone i'm a
student of
observation i i observe things i
remember being being selling cars
saying this is stupid first i learned
how to do it
right customer the 12 steps right
and then i'm like if i do 12 steps with
everybody i can't get 30 units a month
and then i'm like i started skipping
steps
right uh i mean because i wanted i
wanted those ten car
car weeks and the only way to do that
was walk out there and just start
offering people what they had
what they what they were going to ask me
for anyway right
can i get you a price a payment a down
payment a monthly bank can i get you
everything you need
right i knew that it was just a matter
of about 30 seconds they were going to
ask for it all
no doubt so i just basically intercepted
the customer
sped up the processes and and then i'm
like man i started hitting 30 36 units
31 units in 14 days i'm like this is the
way to do it
and then when i lost my job because the
dealer wasn't big enough
didn't think big enough himself didn't
10x
when i left him i didn't have any place
to go
in his company or his organization i
couldn't be a star there
um i went out and started teaching that
hey man everybody how you doing buddy
good how are you you got a book coming
out don't you
uh you just came out where can people
get it
get it on amazon easy spot built to
serve
right there let's go man if you guys
don't know evan follow evan carmichael
he's got a new book out build a serve go
grab it today at amazon
there's a good dude right here rule
number five have long term goals with
elon musk
running a public company is does have
its drawbacks
um so you're not in a hurry no
okay um i mean in the case of tesla and
spacex
uh we we had to raise capital um
and and we had kind of a complex equity
structure that needed to be resolved by
by going public um and
um and so so i thought we kind of needed
to do that in those two cases
we don't have to do that in spacex i
think i think there's a good chance it
will at some point in the future
but but spacex's objectives are super
long term
and and the market is is not so
i'm a bit worried that if we did go
public certainly if we're in public too
soon
that it that that market pressure would
would force us to do
uh short-term things and abandon kind of
long-term projects
like going to mars right greenwire's
very long term rule number six
follow your gut with jamie curran lima
when i look back at all the things i've
i've done i've made so many mistakes but
when i look back at the things i've done
right it was always when i went with my
gut
and and deciding to go to journalism was
one of them because um like you
mentioned in the intro i was
i went to graduate school at columbia
and everyone was getting these
high-paying jobs and
you know you pay a lot of money uh you
know for school
and then you have this pressure um to
get out and get a job or to do something
with it and the average salary was 126
000 that year
out of columbia business school and i
took a job for 23 500
um because i went with what i wanted to
do in my gut what i was passionate about
which was
you know other people's stories and i i
took a job in the middle of washington
state
at a small market but i learned how to
write and edit and
and shoot and film and everything and
just put in the work to try and
build a foundation and rule number seven
the last one before a very special bonus
clip is focus on the a.i with mark cuban
putin says the winner in ai controls the
world china puts together a future plan
saying you know whoever dominates in ai
and they're subsidizing
you know tencent alibaba et cetera
yeah right and that's right they're
they're that's they know it's a race
it is a race we cut our office of
technology and science
to one person who was an assistant to
peter thiel
that's where we stand so when we talk
about infrastructure jobs
you know robots are built in germany and
they're getting by chinese companies in
some respects and i think some japanese
companies bought as well
we don't build robots here very well
right i just invested in my first
robotics company
high robotics that puts robots into
companies um they're in
kansas city i think it is now um but
they
they lease and rent and sell robots into
all these different types of
circumstances to
replace people right but i had to learn
i'm not saying it's a good thing or a
bad thing it's going to happen with or
without me
but i wanted to learn what was going on
those building up
a robotics um industry here
investing in our ai industry here that's
the new infrastructure yeah because if
we don't do it and china or russia win
those wars
we're sol right we're out of luck right
and so when we talk about the price of
assets going up
when if you're hiring you know if you're
talking about intellectual assets if
you're hiring like we were just saying
the price is skyrocketing people you
know montreal has become
the the center of the universe for
computer vision um it's not
us-based schools that are dominating any
longer in those areas we've got a lot of
smart kids
at mit all different schools right and
kids are starting to realize
it's a place for them to go and i'm out
there telling people the first
trillionaire is going to come
from somebody who who comes up with
something really unique in ai
now i've got a special bonus clip that i
think you're going to enjoy but before
that it's time for the question of the
day i want to know what was your single
biggest takeaway from this video and
your plan of action for the next week
when you watch a video and you get
motivated the sign says you have a 35
chance of following through that's not
enough but when you write down what time
what place and how you're going to
actually take action on it
you jump to 91 chance of following
through and when you have public
accountability and you commit
to other people that you're going to do
it it jumps to 95
that you will follow through so i want
that for you believe nation
i want to know your single biggest
takeaway from this video and your plan
of action for the next week
put it down in the comments below so i
can celebrate
you the general theme i would suggest is
that
all trends um are overrated
and so if you think about current trends
in technology
you know uh
healthcare it software education
software
overrated sas enterprise software
really overrated big data
cloud computing if you hear those words
you need to think fraud
you need to run away as fast as you
possibly can um
and um and the reason these buzzwords um
tell you that something um is that
there's these buzzwords they're sort of
like a tell
in poker that people are bluffing and
that there's nothing that there's
uh that the business is not
undifferentiated because the buzzwords
tell you
that it is one company of a category
that's undifferentiated
from the others in that category and
therefore
are symptomatic somehow of of um a lot
of competition
and a bad a bad business idea and so you
know you don't want to be
the fourth online pet food company you
don't want to be the 10th thin film
solar panel company
you don't want to be the 1000th
restaurant in san francisco and so there
is something about
if you can describe what a company is
doing
very straightforwardly by referencing
these these buzzwords these categories
that already exist
that's actually a sign that it's a
pretty bad uh that's
that's a pretty bad idea
[Music]
if you want another video on how
billionaires think check it out
right there next to me i think you'll
enjoy it continue to believe
and i'll see you there you know that's
not really how it works
if you don't love it don't expect others
will either your relationship with time
is such a key component of your life
because when you get caught in a routine
time goes so quickly